most people think you either have to
adopt or conceive a baby to become
legally responsible for a child under
Michigan law that is simply not how it
works I was the father by default these
four men came to the 7 Action News
studios to raise awareness you could
become dad by default there are a couple
ways that happens pastor Edward map says
his previous wife and three children he
loved them as his own then he realized
two of them were not biologically his he
must have been so heartbroken
it was a hurtin thing I don't know you
really want to talk about it cause they
bring tears to my eyes sorry forget
interior idea
pastor Mac says The Betrayal led to
divorce he was shocked when the judge
told him because he was married he
became dad by default he had to pay
support for another man's children let
up a farm let her get the man she laid
down with the people he goes free
I never even slept with her I got a
lawsuit when I was young and she
basically just said that's the money I'm
gonna get and she got it
Reginald Whitlow Anthony Sims and
Carnell Alexander have similar stories
they say women named them out of nowhere
in 2014 7 Action News told Carnell story
and found the mother she said she was
told in order to get welfare benefits
she needed to name a father she knew he
wasn't the dad but wrote down his name
anyway everything is my fault that I put
himself do you think that he should have
to pay this money no you shouldn't have
to pay it off oh my god she said that
and there's know for a fact she still
took the money - the money the money
there and I'm gonna take it coz there's
no way if he was getting those checks
returned to him every time he was sent
to you he wouldn't be out here
complaining so you definitely kept that
money yeah
then these men missed paternity hearings
because they were either sick or did not
receive notice Carnell had proof he was
in prison when a process server claimed
he was served at a house in Highland
Park when they didn't show up at court a
judge ruled to them dads by default they
then missed their chance to challenge it
with DNA evidence by the court deadline
because they couldn't find the women and
children they wouldn't give me her
address
because it was confidential these men
all eventually got DNA tests backing
their store
so you want them to get DNA test but if
they don't know the children or the
mothers and they don't know where they
live how they supposed to get the DNA
test too late
often times it does make a difference
representative Jim Rhon said says those
DNA tests should make a difference the
Republican from White Lake says he heard
the story of Carnell Alexander on 7
Action News and decided to take action
he says this year he hopes to pass
legislation that would protect men from
being forced to pay for another man's
children from the research I've done I
don't know if that law has been passed
through but I couldn't find anything on
it being passed so that's very towing so
people that are for equality what huh
nothing else over the years Edward
battery had his driver's license
stripped and once even found himself in
handcuffs over child support payments
for a child that's not his I would hate
to see somebody else go through the same
thing I've been going through this me
heydays this mound of paperwork shows a
juvenile court judge ordered him to pay
child support even before the birth snig
is paying fetus support what for not his
fetus he was annexed ovary support there
were technically if let's call it a date
is it I mean we pay him you wanna fire
guns blazing Papa seems that little
really inspired you hey spread them
chiefly though I didn't do a voluntary
acknowledgement I didn't sign the birth
certificate all I know is when
legitimated the child in your name
battery asked several judges during
several hearings for a DNA test but no
judge ordered one I said how did I even
get put on child support and I never
said this was my child and they said
again this is not what we here for
why
that's not what we here for we just here
for your money
carry on and he supported for years was
not biologically his he took the
documentation to court the judge
wouldn't accept it but ordered a new DNA
test done that showed the same results
probability of paternity zero percent
isn't that one of the few times in life
where you want to see a zero percent on
a piece of paper yeah like it's funny
how the law supposed to work like like
without reasonable doubt and now you
have nothing in your life yeah now [ __ ]
it so it still you crazy it's crazy
they never didn't do what they were
originally supposed to do which was give
me the opportunity to take a DNA test I
was just a voice not being heard so I
guess I needed a choir Juvenile Court
magistrate Nancy Kessler agreed in
October to allow battery to disestablish
paternity but only after he says she
admonished him we're taking it this far
the judge stated that well I don't I
find it very distasteful that your
bastardizing a child that was the line
that set me off so what you know what
kills me is that people always feel like
yeah but the law said that sometimes the
law is [ __ ] up your bastardizing butt
shot it not mine
you know who bastard I'd that child the
man who slept with her who's actually
the father maybe he don't know maybe he
does maybe he doesn't even know okay
well you know what listen here's the
thing there's clear bias he's in Family
Court and divorce law settlements okay
this stuff is very well documented it's
very well made even by most feminist
websites they will admit to this but
remember that men's
versus feminists conversation they had
on Jubilee where the feminists said well
there's plenty of organizations that are
advocating for this well booboo I did my
searching I did not find one okay listen
now but I know you came here with your
little researches and she sounds like
maybe she's maybe I'm wrong I looked
nothing but I did find one article from
everyday feminism
do you remember everyday feminism no
Riley J Dennis in partnership with so we
had an article and they said the truth
about father and bison family courts so
I decided to research this topic every
intention of creating a piece about how
institutionalized sexism in the legal
system affects men too but the results
of my research were surprising to say
the least
it's true that mothers are more likely
to receive custody of their children and
divorce but the source of the bias is
not in the course it's in the marriage
the institution of straight marriage
prep rates rates patriarchal gender
roles during the marriage as well as
during the during its complainant
divorce the same unfair assumptions that
undermine the tradition of straight
marriages are the ones that mire their
divorces statistically it appears that
family courts in the United States are
biased against a father's for example 83
percent of mothers receive custody of
their children and divorces
additionally men are awarded less
support on average and mothers who are
awarded support there is also plenty of
anecdotal evidence citing situations
where mothers were awarded custody in
spite of fathers demonstrating interest
and potential to provide care for their
children even if the courts are biased
they are not biased because they dislike
men they are biased because they are
reflecting the patriarchal notion that
men are not meant to be caregivers and
that women are not meant to be
breadwinners so the people that
suffering is men so and you know what I
like about this it just seems to absolve
women of all responsibility in this it's
like saying because the systems in place
and now women are benefiting from it
Aurum wounds are ones who are engaging
that woman's fob that would be like me
saying that because why people you know
really started the slave trade here in
North America specifically that if black
people today were to own slaves
we have no culpability because white
people created the system out here and
in the first place no if I choose to own
slaves today I'm still a piece of [ __ ]
the same way if you are using the
advantages of family court to your
benefit as a woman you are engaging the
practices that disadvantaged men ie a
piece of [ __ ] that is what it is
nobody's telling these women to use
their advantages and their influence in
the family court system but they are
willfully engaging in it they are
willfully taking more money than four
men then they should be allowed to so
you are participating in the system that
you pretend you have nothing to do with
patriarchy you know what I love about
these discussions this is why I hate
talking to super wolf people every time
you bring up anything everything is a
result of everything is just patriarchy
I miss you and she's just a way for a
lot of people did not accept any
responsibility that's not me as them
here's a second point they demonize
women of course a women are always a
victim even a family course where
they're clearly advantage it's always
about how women are bad some say nasty
even abusive mothers manipulate the laws
that are already in place in their favor
in order to keep their children away
from their fathers there they call this
malicious mother syndrome is there some
basis for these stereotypes
unfortunately yes so huh think that all
the mothers or most of the mothers who
filed for divorce want to keep their
children from their fathers out of spite
with utter disregard for their
children's best interests in
relationships is unfair and unfounded
who fed that who's fed back to straw men
in fact the majority of custody battle
myths the in fact the majority of
custody settlements even those that
favor the mother are reached by mutual
agreements outside the courtroom why do
you think that is it's because the man
knows he's not going to win in court and
I ain't gonna dash out a bunch of cash I
don't have to try to not win something
that's why they're not fighting they
prefer to sell it because it saves them
money in a losing effort we third point
the values fathers rights over
children's rights the greatest issue
with some of these fathers rights
organizations that they put personal
rights and interest over the rights of
the children there are extenuating
circumstances when mothers are not
suited to be in the children's likes but
more often than not the children benefit
from having both their mother and their
father
picture unfortunately often these
organizations offer methods to minimize
child support that sort of greed has a
direct effect on the child's lives of
children yeah the reason why they want
to minimize child support is oftentimes
it's because it's not logical how much
it is a lot of child support is far too
elevated this is very biased feminist
organizations don't truly advocate for
men's issues and that's why I say I
understand why there is a need for men's
rights activists because there are palms
that are mostly directed men and it
makes sense to have a movement that
recognizes and wants to address those
problems specifically but what do the
feminist movements do they just blame
men for their own problems we don't need
your help because you can't help us and
you don't seem interested in it because
it's not about idea today it's not
really about equality and it's just a
small percentage of you that are for
equality is not about equality it's
equal it's gonna be equality what it
benefits you and when it doesn't it's
not gonna be equal no more and you're
not gonna fight for it which I
understand and that's why there's that's
why does the opposite there's the
opposition right as a reason why so I
just wanted to bring this up to say
feminists can say whatever they want
about how feminist advocates for men -
you don't and it's fine
and it's actually fine but when
someone's gonna advocate for men you
can't be mad about that that's it so
that's all I really want to get into we
wanna know your thoughts leave your
comments below